Nèa em y tạm thông mề hay, bố chừng có phòng các mùi chia tên xe ha đã lên tiếng, làm gió những thông tin bị hiểu nhằm
liên quan để lệnh bắn rất khăn bùi chia và thái lần. Đan đưa tại của học đặc biệt của bạn,
miền giới chung, ở bây xe. Theo ông, với yệu lực bắt đầu từ chương ngày 20 bại thống mề hay,
thật tộng lương bản là công kết lâu sải trong phạm hông phải chí cấu sải trong bệm hay dờ như một số ý kiện
dùi đoán. Bố chừng tiền xe a chương miét, mốc bệm nhaa dờ chí áp dùng chú về thực hiện nội dông, chào chả,
mười tả mình sẽ cảm buồn chia, phù hợp với tình thần tuyên bố chung của là làm pơ khi nè hai mi sao thống người.
Bây viê thái lần, bố tức lạnh của 2 thống báo, tình kinh giọc bình dời đã hạnh nhận,
dù vẫn kinh nhằm số hoạt động dù chuyển của lực dường cảm buồn chia. Bằng có khẳng định đang kiểm soát
tình gình cho phạm vi lạnh thổ của mình. Bây giờ bán có hiệu lực nhận được số hoạt động đồng của tế,
phải cuo sai như mà lấy chá chung của và miếp thì tục kêu có hai nữa.
Tục kiện nghiêm tục các cảm kết vi là ý phạm bình báo để khu vực.